the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome to the bonus show
anthony weiner former congressman his
stint in prison starts today he was or
maybe this yesterday was this article
from yesterday I'm not sure the date on
it it started or is about to start let's
put it that way he is turning himself in
or did turn himself in for a 21 month
sentence for sexting with a 15 year old
girl he is going to be at a facility in
suburban Boston so he is going to be in
our area now I don't know which one this
is there is that that prison you can see
from the Turnpike when you're driving
east off to the right yeah well it's
gonna be a federal prison I think it's
in Danvers do you feel that we are in
danger because of Anthony Weiner's close
proximity to us I don't oh yeah I mean
he's in tip-top shape as we learned from
that those pictures yes and oh yeah
maybe he could break out of prison
danger I wonder what the day-to-day I
haven't seen it I'm sure there will be I
don't know what exactly this prison is
like you know how some of these federal
prisons like we've talked to Bob ney who
was convicted in the Jack Abramoff
lobbying scandal and he did like 16
months or something like that and he
said it was really pretty relaxed you
know these these federal white-collar
type places now the sexting with a 15
year old is not exactly white-collar but
Anthony Weiner is a former honourable
member of the House of Representatives
so maybe he gets a better better better
housing or something like that the
question I was thinking of is do any of
us really think that 21 months in prison
will fundamentally change who he is with
regard to these impulses because this is
the type of thing that people do where
clearly there's something something is
wrong mentally right because he knows
that this stuff isn't right he's been
doing this stuff for a while it's it's
ruined his life he had an opportunity to
get beyond it and then he did it again
and again and again I don't think that
21 months is actually going to change
anything for him right I think if
anything was the change in mood would
just be like the public shame that
happened over and over again I mean
having to resign
as a congressman the embarrassment and
then you know he actually was in first
place in the New York City mayor's race
yeah and then that second chapter came
out I mean would time behind bars change
him I don't know yeah I just don't know
this possibility though that he may not
pursue sexting with underage girls right
off of this keep it only to illegal
adults or something like that it is I do
kind of feel bad for the entire thing
because I do think he's like I think
he's just a mentally ill guy I don't
think he's a bad guy and actually his
politics as a politician I always found
him to be pretty smart and to bring
pretty good ideas to the table so I
actually do feel bad to some extent
because I feel like this is someone
who's sick do you buy into the sex
addiction idea do you think that's
actually a thing I think it's not about
sex per se I think it's more about lack
of impulse control and it could be any
any one of other things like it could
have been that he got sucked into drugs
it could have been that he got sucked
into gambling and I and I don't remember
if he actually had a gambling gambling
problem or not for some reason that's in
my mind I don't know that it's about sex
per se I think it's more about like the
whole the whole that sex fills in his
life or something like that if that
makes sense
I don't know very interesting it's
always funny how right-wingers try to
act as if we're not willing to talk
about the story you're like oh yeah
literally with Harvey Weinstein -
because he was a progressive guy young
into the Hillary just because we're on
the left as well no we'll call it out
when we see it - not only that I think
we mentioned a few months ago when
Anthony Weiner was sentenced that
there's no one on the left defending
this guy right I mean I have no qualms
whatsoever just simply saying I I
thought his politics were pretty good he
was great debater - great debater but I
haven't seen anybody on the left
defending this guy in any way so anyway
the 21 month sentence begins do you know
offhand if he gets time off for good
behavior or when you get a 21-month
federal sentence like this do you have
to serve the whole thing I don't know
and actually I'm second-guessing if it's
even Danvers that he was sent - oh well
I know that it's called Devin's 7 that's
it that's it 7 but I don't know what
town it's in or what anyway it's an it's
in the suburban Boston area it's in an
area where a three-bedroom home probably
costs two million dollars that but that
it has nothing no bearing on how nice
the prison is because again he's being
brought up from New York
Jerzy wherever it was that he lead lives
have you heard this thing before pat
where if once you've been up for
something like 19 or 20 hours you were
effectively as cognitively impaired as
if you were drunk I don't know to what
degree but a pretty significant amount
like three four drinks or something like
yeah your driving abilities the same
even if you get three or four hours of
sleep it's about on par with if you were
drink driving drunk right exactly so
we've all heard those bullet points
thrown around there's a new study which
was looking directly at neurons in the
brains of 12 people and it wanted to
test what is the effect on the neurons
of the brain of sleep deprivation and it
slows down the communication of the
neurons that are used for brain cells to
effectively talk to each other this was
reported yesterday in Nature Medicine
and this is now getting to sort of the
underlying science of why sleep impairs
a range of different mental functions
and it's the idea that when we think
about the drunk drunk driving and being
driving sleep-deprived is an interesting
one because when your neuron
communication speed slows down someone
jumps out in front of your car you are
literally delayed in how quickly you can
respond and react to that compared to
whether you are well-rested and I am
convinced I've been taught I know I'm
almost like a broken record with this
the culture in the u.s. around work
hours busyness and how little people
sleep our president being a great
example bragging for decades about
sleeping four to five hours a night
that's all he gets he doesn't need
anymore
I think it is dangerous in so many ways
one in that it becomes normalized and
it's really bad for health we know that
people have a much higher risk of
premature death if they sleep under
seven hours a night for long periods of
time just just science right we know
that and when you look at the level of
impairment that is associated with sleep
deprivation it is a major health crisis
a public health crisis yeah especially
if you think about truck drivers - I
mean their driving hours on end and
oftentimes they don't get that eight
hours of sleep that they need right
there logging it because I guess there
are often incentives for getting your
product shipped oh my god yeah way
faster than the designated time it would
take if you got your full eight hours of
sleep every course yeah I had a my
physics professor in high school
actually who was a great physics
professor he moonlit moonlighted I don't
know what the right moonlighted yeah it
seems like it would be moonlit but that
doesn't really sound right
anyway he moonlighted as a regional
truck driver so he wouldn't do like the
cross-country stuff yes to get back for
school he has to be back for school
exactly but on weekends he would do
regional like maybe go to from you know
from Western Massachusetts to Michigan
and back South Carolina like still
pretty far but not cross country and he
would talk about how at the time this
was 2001 where I had him as a professor
he was moving from the manual log
keeping where you're just responsible
for having a piece of paper in your
truck at all times where you put when
you started and stopped and if you don't
have that he would say like if I didn't
log when I was off sleeping last night
if I got pulled over and they looked at
that I could get fined it was some crazy
amount like 500 bucks 750 bucks enough
that it would almost make the entire job
not worth it he said that at the time
they were starting to transition to all
electronic devices and that it's much
harder to cheat those because we can all
imagine how you just fill in yeah I
slept eight hours but really it was five
and then you continue but that is a
major major issue and what I don't know
enough about trucking to know but what
I've been told is that it's tougher to
lie about time about rest time with the
new electronic monitors which also know
if the truck is moving and this type of
thing if you stop at a truck stop take
exam hours of sleep but I don't know if
there are new ways to circumvent the new
electronic monitors I don't know when's
the last time you pulled an all-nighter
never you've never pulled it all night
now no no no I mean I've had some nights
where I had a really hard time getting
to sleep and for different reasons ended
up sleeping almost nothing at all I I
would say the closest thing to
all-nighters that I pull is when I
travel to Europe those are all red eye
flights and because of the time change
they're often six-and-a-half hour
flights from Boston and you leave at 7
p.m. and when you land because of the
time change at 7 a.m. and they serve
dinner they serve breakfast you might
only get 90 minutes or an hour to really
try to sleep on the plane that's
closest thing I'm not in I'm into
getting sleep for sure when I was in
high school in college I was a
procrastinator but I was also a
perfectionist which is a dangerous
combination because if you if you wait
until 10 o'clock at night to start that
paper yep you're not gonna get any sleep
and so I would have the you know a full
day and then stay up throughout the
night and then be up the entire day the
next day yeah and so I was up you know
at times up to 40 hours at a time that's
bad that's not that's really really bad
yeah I don't I've never even tried to do
that and fortunately it's never happened
accidentally and I hope it doesn't
because it's I don't do well when I
haven't slept well I really don't you
can talk to my girlfriend about that I
am an incredibly grumpy it's very odd
because you go back and forth between
feeling incredibly awake like you got
some caffeine rush right they've just
being completely drowsy yeah well they
riad or all that will do that to you
yeah so that explains that Larry David
is being criticized by the
anti-defamation league and by other
groups because he made some jokes about
pickup lines and dating in Holocaust
concentration camps during his Saturday
Saturday Night Live hosting over the
weekend during the opening monologue and
of course Larry David is Jewish and he
was talking about Harvey Weinstein and
the entire disgrace and shame of Harvey
Weinstein and the sexual harassment what
would you call it snowball firestorm
that Harvey Weinstein has on the middle
of ant pile on yeah I like that and well
although pile on kind of implies that
it's unfair I think it's perfectly fair
what's going on oh yeah it's people are
certainly pilot the number of
allegations are piling on that's for
damn sure
and there are people criticizing Larry
David I don't actually have a problem in
principle with a holocaust joke and I'm
not even going to say that it has to be
a Jewish person who makes the joke I
think it's all context I my criticism is
I didn't find the Holocaust stuff from
the Larry David monologue super funny
like if it had been really really clever
I might say no there was some kind of
like greater social point combined with
really interesting and clever humor
involved in it I thought that it was an
attempt to be provocative that fell a
little bit flat yeah so he said you know
he was always checking out
when he was younger and that he wonders
if he was bored and Poland and you know
a time that would put him into the
Holocaust concentration camp yeah if he
would still be checking out women there
right and of course if you've read if
you if you if you have read le vie
Zell's night for example you would be
pretty acutely aware that you weren't
thinking about what women you could hit
on when you were in a holocaust
concentration camp never get out right
or if you would ever get out you open up
something there note no doubt about it
so I was not I didn't find it offensive
I I did find it not particularly funny
so that's but I don't have really have
much else to say about it it's
interesting I mean I don't think he
would have made that joke if he didn't
have a Jewish background and I think
probably not family members that were
killed in the Holocaust as well I didn't
know that yeah they had this whole
exposure about his his past he actually
have some Confederate background too
did you watch the Henry Louis Gates PBS
thing yes they did you were on that they
did the DNA background and and like
family tree of Burnie and Larry David
because I was Bernie was played by Larry
David on prior Saturday Night Live
episodes fascinating yeah they found out
that Larry David had some slave-owning
family which is it's not particularly
common or rare among American Jewish
families like something I mean there
were some that owned slaves that that's
basically it yeah
doesn't say about him - no certainly not
yeah okay so anyway I I did not find it
so much offensive as I found it funny
under your thoughts
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]